welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with
snowpiercer finally pumping the brakes
on its first season it's time to talk
about the off the rails ending and how
things could be getting back on track
for next time both episodes 9 and 10
drop back to back and there's a lot to
unpack throughout this video we'll be
going through the ins and outs of each
entry as well as what we took from the
ending and what could happen going
forward obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check them out yet then I
highly recommend that you check out now
make sure you drop a thumbs up if you
enjoyed the weekly breakdowns and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel for
videos on your favorite series every
week without the way thank you for
clicking this let's get into our ending
explained of snowpiercer okay so episode
9 actually opens up with the POV of
melody who's pretty much been an
antihero throughout the entire show she
says that she subtly tried to tear down
the ideas of Wilfred and in their place
prop up a better world that isn't based
on his rules episode 9 especially seems
to be based around the idea that
everyone thinks they know best 5 out
when given the opportunity they still
rely on the old ways and things that
have come before
thus they don't break the cycle Melanie
is still basing her ideals of wilford's
and this is exemplified by the books in
a study that she looks to for guidance
there's also commander Grey in Ruth who
both want things to remain exactly the
same so it was pointless asking Melanie
in the first place Layton causes a
revolution but when he gains power he's
pretty much left with a society that
resembles the one he was rebelling
against all in all there's a lot going
on and it does paint Melanie out as a
very complex character that definitely
feels that are most vulnerable in this
episode we actually see her being kind
to the talese I think her being propped
in there with them as shown firsthand
that she was probably too cruel to them
however as she says the Train demanded
blood and to me this is pretty much
commenting on how society often demands
sacrifice and the use of fear in order
to stop chaos
without the notion of punishment we
would all simply do as we pleased and
this is exemplified by the paper maker
who's executed in the opening to set an
example to others that might consider
joining the revolution the Train
demanding blood also plays massively
into the end of episode 9 in which
Layton is forced to sacrifice his
prisoner carriage and yeah lots of
things going on now these episodes are
very much about the uprisings and though
there are certain power plays in moments
on the whole they're pretty
straightforward until probably the last
15 minutes of episode 10 now the main
metaphor of the entire uprising is how
the 1% can not operate without the other
99 whereas the 99 can probably function
without the one we see in first class
which is of course a play on the number
1 itself that should the workforce be
fully killed off they would be left with
nothing and thus they're put into a
tight corner where they have to promise
new leadership and that things will
change this is of course often shown an
up-and-coming politicians running for
election who make promises to change
things and they either don't deliver or
don't fully fulfill things to the extent
that they said they would this only
leaves things open to go one way and
that is that the tale will take over and
try and prop up a new person in power
however it doesn't seem like if Layton's
revolution succeeds that he would
actually know how to run the economy on
the train and it's definitely a
fascinating aspect of the show
I loved watching play out lane is
offered the opportunity to hand himself
over and Melanie is rescued by jingchou
and javi you've seen firsthand how she
runs things and know that the Train is
being built in a certain way which
relies on her rules
Dulles has reduced the train to the
haves and have-nots everything is in a
precise order for a specific reason
without this order everything descends
into people trying to survive no matter
what and this is exemplified in Zara who
of course sacrificed Josie and a child
for our own life now with her Layton
realizes he's a father and it really
puts him into a vulnerable position but
hey Zara just wanted a man back and I
guess don't hate the player hate the
game
now it's upon activating the radio in
episode 9 that we get our first tease of
how the show will end a radio signal can
be heard
this sets up the reveal that there's
another train which not only has Wilfred
on board but also Melanie's daughter
we'll discuss this later in the video
but it's important to bear in mind that
in the world of snowpiercer there are
actually far more trains than we're
aware of though we don't see them all
the graphic novel states that there
could be up to ten navigating the planet
and these arcs have all been put in
place to not only provide humanity with
a lifeboat but also so that Wilfred has
other retreats
should he be ousted like we saw with
Melanie now speaking of Melanie she goes
to Layton and tells him of a way to
defeat the army and promises to hand
over the power she has so that Layton
can lead we did kind of have a feeling
that Melanie will be kept around due to
her being the only one that could fix
the train I liked how she saw abdicated
power after admitting her way didn't
work we have an awesome decoupling scene
in which Melanie pulls off a maneuver
that separates the Train and then pulls
it back together with the army released
into the world to either starve or
freeze
I love how when Layton hands himself
over they make him hold up a white flag
which of course means surrender this
jerk supposes the red flag which has
been used throughout the series to
signal war and of course defiance the
scene in which the train breaks apart is
great and it reminded me of an old
mission on Final Fantasy 8 so I found it
thrilling to watch they pretty much got
rid of the dead weight but unfortunately
in order to carry out the plan Layton
also had to cut off the prisoner car
which as you can guess contain a lot of
his friends it's at his point that he
made the tough decision and probably
realized firsthand that making
sacrifices isn't easy it's something
that melanie has had to do several times
for the greater good and thus he ends up
sending many of his allies to their
death it's a big gut punch that showed
the series continued to operate in
shades of grey rather than black and
white but I guess we should have seen it
coming with the finale being called 994
cause long stood still oh it's a tough
watch now I actually have a feeling that
these characters will be back and that
it could have been rescued by Welford
who as we learn is operating out about
the Folgers of course help the paper the
train and Wilfred would definitely have
use for the people that Layton cut off
Melanie seemed to sort of manipulate the
situation and put it in Layton's hands
and I think that she may have set this
up as an ace up her sleeve to expose him
should he ever try to betray her
we know that Melanie likes to hide her
true intentions and she did this with
Myles and of course Wilfred Layton of
course wins and ends up becoming the
leader and Lafayette gets his a
revolution I love you Hamilton now he
delivers the bad news about GOC to Myles
I'm actually surprised at how little he
cared about what Melanie did she locked
him in a drawer killed his girlfriend
and yet stabbed his people but she did
kill the Folgers so yeah fair enough now
Layton tells the people that they are in
control and they passed through Chicago
which is the city that it all started in
this marks a revolution aka is sort of
New Year celebration of the train going
around the globe once more LJ goes to
her cabin and sees that it's been
overrun she was of course instrumental
in the revolution and was pretty much
the reason that the rebels were even
able to gain access to the Train LJ
becomes close to Bregman John I think
that going forward he will fill the role
of her bodyguard who as we know became a
serial killer under her command she is
clearly going to want to take back the
power that she's lost I think that in
the second season she's slowly gonna
make several place however I can see it
having a worse outcome for LJ as she
won't have the wilford secrets to lord
over Melanie and will hopefully finally
be sent to her death either way LJ is
going to have to face her own demons as
is Melanie who takes a psychological
trip into her biggest regret which is of
course leaving her daughter behind now
what's interesting here is that the
music that accompanies this is very
similar to the mild bursts we hear on
the radio throughout the season
we've never learned who Melanie's
daughter's father was I think that this
music indicates that it might actually
be Wilfred and this explains why he went
to get her for his own train clearly
Alexander has been put in a position of
power and I only make sense that she
would be so far up the Train if she was
connected to Wilfred as much as she was
Melanie there's definitely a possibility
that Wilfred and Melanie were going out
at one point and became estranged before
working to get
on completing the train that's just a
theory but obviously let me know your
thoughts below now of course we are here
to talk about the ending which confirms
that Wilfred is indeed alive so all the
draw theories are now mute and Sean Bean
will indeed be portraying the character
in the flesh we learn that Wilfred has
been aboard big Alice which is a supply
train that has been racing around the
planet Alice I believe is a play on the
word alias which the name derives from
and originally this meant something
additional before being used as a
meaning for a pseudonym Wilfred clearly
kept this train around to basically
rebuild snowpiercer
as it's stacked with pots I also think
that he had it just in case there was a
mutiny and it shows that perhaps
Melanie's thoughts on him were misguided
and then he had a plan all along Wilfred
is clearly back to ruin the revolution
and take over the Train and he actually
manages to catch up to them attaches
onto the back with one of the coolest
clamps I've ever seen unhinges the
daughter board and sends in Melanie's
daughter I love the way that the W flips
around to an M suggesting that this is
indeed Wilfred strain but it has been
subverted to Melanie's now Melanie says
that she will not fall in line under his
leadership again but I do believe with
him basically doing what she did with
Myles enlighten that she's pretty much
gonna have to we of course cut away
before we get to see Wilfred but the
final scene leaves a lot of clues to
indicate how things could be going now
your first question is likely how did
Wilfred survive well as we see Melanie
herself dons a suit in the episode that
allows her to operate in the wilderness
and I believe that she would have left
Wilfred with one of these as she only
said that she left him to die rather
than killing him outright the second
question is probably well what will
happen to Melanie well due to having
this suit and being on the outside she
survives from falling from the Train and
with it being stopped she can likely
board Alice from the back and go and
face Wilfred head-on we close with
someone sitting at the back of the Train
which is likely the megalomaniac himself
and see Melanie heading towards it so I
do think that the two will meet soon
your third question if I'm using my
psychic powers correctly is does this
tie in with the movie
well we have kind of been wondering
whether the show would be part of the
overall continuity or not and they've
done a great job of leaving things open
for them to either build their own thing
or make it all part of the universe we
don't know for definite but due to the
way that the show ends I do lean more
towards it being part of the greater
universe Wilfred definitely has the
potential to take over the train
add in the parts that make it more
aligned with the film and yet connect
these two worlds together now going
forward in the original graphic novel we
learn that there's another train called
icebreaker that many of the characters
end up boarding to escape snow PSA due
to the spread of a virus that moves its
way of the carriages probably too soon
to be doing something like that but the
second season has mostly been filmed so
it shouldn't be delayed too much I think
in the show the virus will be replaced
with the forces of Wilfred who will
initially take over snowpiercer
and he will bring his own engine aboard
which is something that happens in the
original work the deserters of
snowpiercer
may flee to Icebreaker and they will
spend their time trying to avoid
colliding with the train all whilst
balancing the economy on board in the
graphic novel this was due to the
population on board snowpiercer being
wiped out by the disease but I do think
they may take things in a slightly
different direction with that basically
being a war between the two trains in
the source material the survivors
actually ended up leaving the train at
one point and going off into the real
world
this was also shown in the film and the
comic book series ends with a small
patch of flowers being shown coming out
of the Thor dice suggesting that life is
continued outside of the Train much like
how the movie hints at I'm not sure
exactly where things will go but I do
believe that the upcoming season will
center around a sort of Val between
Melanie and Wilfred potentially with her
or rather their daughter caught in the
middle it's definitely going to make for
a gripping show going ahead and I really
can't wait to see what happens when it
drops
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the show as a whole and
where you think things could be going
next time make sure you comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy the
video then please drop a thumbs up and
if you missed any of our coverage it's
gonna be linked after this if you've
been watching along with us week by week
and thank you for all your support
towards the channel
and I hope you enjoyed it as much as we
did if you want to come chat us after
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below those are the best
ways skipping today with the channel so
hopefully we see over there but if not
thanks for watching till the end of the
video I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]